hello welcome to this video playing a
stigmatised so let's do something else
there okay I don't get to play the
tomorrow this is a good opening though
something that I recommend to myself
people ask me form sidelines in the
Sicilian yeah I don't like it d 5 takes
Knight eggs I mean this is supposed to
be okay but I'm not a fan group d 1 yeah
they have been games with this by am
think I'm Pookie Adams at this one game
where you got a really good position out
of this okay I try to make a deform a
little bit more difficult to achieve yep
why not it's a healthy development and I
cannot play b6 because of the diagonal
yo and he's ready to go before anyway
yeah to plug it of course Lee this is
not my standard opening what I wanted to
do something else besides the usual if
45 stuff yes you for now probably why
they're slightly better mm that's not
something I expected it looks very
weakening why should actually play some
plane is more of a positional way here
with playing under playing on them Quinn
side in the center bit surprised that he
but he played like that okay jack so
Bishop c5 isn't that a bit of an
annoyance for him we cannot d4 is
attacked how the same who does he handle
this he cannot take and so on Queen d7
isn't that winning like resides yes yeah
it's winning so Quincy 6 also wins wins
the house yeah f4 was was a stranger
strange move I think white is slightly
better in this position if he plays
normally like this um it's pretty pretty
standard kind of position where white
has with the three pawns yes chances
long-term to do something on the
queenside and it's got them a bit more
space this kind of position could easily
rise from the Catalan for example itself
more than that it's hard to say it's a
default color position but um it's not
very easy for only typical at same yeah
that probably play some
i gladiate next what is just a bit more
comfortable he has maybe 95 here going
to the engine I can also go with 88 yeah
let's head why does a little bit better
and therefore is probably a wrong idea
and it shouldn't lose immediately but
this is this does I'd probably lose the
game yeah very very quickly um this g3
is not a bad line actually it's been
played by Carlton as well um I think d5
is probably best but I wasn't really up
for this kind of position wanted to do
something else in any fire I think this
is this is fairly good at this is
something that can be recommended to why
play there's a non theoretical way way
to play against this opening okay well
thanks for watching